thank you good morning the time is 11 31
therefore i reconvene the meeting i'm
councillor rogers and i'm the chair of
this licensing subcommittee
meeting to introduce everyone who is
present at this remote meeting i will
kindly ask that you confirm your
attendance
and your role or job title when i say
your name
counselor aura counselor for cinderella
in ramsey councillor wing
councillor for central harbour in
ramsgate
phillips jennifer phillips the principal
litigation lawyer for thanet council
mr clapson democratic services officer
uh james clapson mr brown
he doesn't seem to be here okay
miss brock allison brock
technical support manager ms docker
no pc greg
no no miss tully
that's joe fulton tolley owner of skin
beating tonight
mr hadden no i'm miss wilcox no
have i missed anyone present here today
i think that's it thanks chad if you
have technical difficulties during the
meeting
then please contact katie the democratic
services officer
on call who will attempt to assist you
she will put her phone number in the
chat function
agenda item 4 application for a new club
premises certificate
the gold room vip private club
i call upon ms phillips the council's
principal litigation solicitor to
explain to the parties
the procedure that we will be taking
during this hearing thank you
thank you very much good morning i would
like everyone present
to know that the decisions made by the
subcommittee are made in accordance with
the licensing act
2003 and are based on the information
presented in this agenda together with
any verbal submissions
that are being made today decisions of
the subcommittee
are not politically based this
subcommittee must
act impartially and offer a fair and
unbiased
hearing of today's application
we are here to consider the application
for a new premises
certificate for the gold room vip
private club situated at seven high
street margate kent
ct 9 1dl under
section 17 of the licensing act 2003.
the applicant has applied for a new club
premises certificate
to supply alcohol on the premises along
with
live and recorded music and two
representations
have been made in relation to the
application and also the application
includes the operating hours between 9am
and 10pm and we will hear the parties in
the following order
the licensing officer first and then the
applicant
for the premises certificate and then
followed by any representations
each party has up to 15 minutes to make
its
presentation and this includes any
witness called
and during your presentation you will
not be
allowed to introduce new evidence at
this stage
than has been provided in the
documentation that you have provided
to the committee thus far following each
invitation the members of the
subcommittee may ask questions
of each party or their representative
or any witnesses and there is no time
limit for the members questions
there is no automatic right for the
parties to question
one another except with permission
and at the end of the proceedings each
party will have five minutes
to make a closing statement in the
following order
the applicant for the license and any
representatives
and the licensing authority please note
to ensure
that this virtual meeting runs smoothly
so therefore we ask that only one
individual speak at a time
any person speaking must be permitted to
finish what they're saying without
interrupting and the
chair will direct further on that
procedure
the meeting will then adjourn for the
subcommittee to consider its decision
when we adjourn the subcommittee members
the legal officer myself and the clerk
shall leave the virtual meeting
and if you'd like to hear the decision
of the subcommittee
i advise that um the decision the
deliberations
will take approximately 30 minutes from
the time of the
adjournment you can either remain in the
virtual meeting
during this time or you can use the link
again to re-access the meeting
if you do decide to wait in the virtual
meeting room please turn off your
cameras and microphones
to ensure your privacy as the recording
will
continue thank you very much thank you
i would like to stress the importance of
following the hearing procedure
and that there will be an opportunity
for all parties to make a final
presentation
after questioning therefore i would
advise all present
to please follow the procedure and to
respect those speaking by not
interrupting
or speaking over others if people do
interrupt or speak over others
i as chairman will ask them to refrain
from doing so
if they continue to do so after my
warning then that individual could face
being asked to leave the meeting
could the licensing officer please
present their report
good morning everyone this application
is for a club promises certificate at
seven high street
margate the application was advertised
as it should be
and the we received two representations
these are attached at annex three i've
also done a summary of the hours and
activities requested
these are annex ii when we receive
representations we try and negotiate
between the two parties to try and come
to some agreement obviously to stop it
going this far
and the applicant replied to the
comments from the objections these are
attached to annex 4
and the reply from one of the objectors
is also attached to annex 5.
and x6 has the comments of the
environmental health department
and the fire service have inspected the
premises and they have no injections and
that's that annex
fix and then annex a we've got two
emails in support of the application the
committee's decision is requested
thank you thank you
would the applicant please present their
application
so can you unmute your microphone
aha can you hear me okay wonderful
okay so my name is joe fulton tully i'm
a business developer an entrepreneur
and a crisis manager of over 25 years
in the beautiful beauty retail leisure
um
and in industries as well and i'm
currently the owner here at homestead
margate
and manson and my career is taking it
all over the south
of the england and into london and i've
been an active part of the local
community
and i'm passionate about the local
community community
and i've been involved in many setups of
local businesses
um in consultation fashion including
monksville farm
and blue wave gin which is local and i
worked behind the bars of barnacles
and also as far back as bradstone mill
in the late 90s
and my personal focus on business is to
offer something extra
and at the highest standard possible and
i often feel that this particular
industry that i'm in
the heavy duty industry being
unregulated
can fail its responsibilities and it's
not something that
um i i aspire to be identified to be
more than that
um which is why the vip standard is very
important
and i've already demonstrated how
serious i am about business
and about standards i have a great
relationship with um
tdc licensing and i currently have a
needle
premises license uh in the building
my overhearing skills become an
experience not just
haircut and become part central for
community
i am not a discount brand i don't stack
them high and get into my high profits
and i'm an affordable luxury brand and
i have a demographic client here that
our latest journalism between 40s and
60s
and to the late 60s we even have babies
and i want to provide my regular clients
with something extra
and and so the vip club was born
and the clients here are invited to join
the club
uh which entitles them to discount on
retail products
and exclusive invitations to promotions
and events
and these are usually circulated around
things like product launches or new
treatments they're providing
the business and we already have had and
provided
entertainment evenings over the last
year um
last two years where people can come and
experience an event
and we have our first charity event
which is part of our vip club which is
found in june 2022.
um in line with my
uh very high standards i have taken my
responsibility very seriously
as a professional running business and i
decided because we wanted to serve
alcohol to our clients while they're in
the business having treatments
and that i wanted to have a certificate
um club premises certificate and to make
sure that we're
observing the four key licensing
objectives
uh i would like to point out at this
time um that the objections that have
been
raised by the local um president i feel
that they're
presuming that we are entertaining a
priority a propriety club
functioning for profit and therefore um
their concerns are not in line with the
certificate i have applied for
i will stipulate again that we are not a
profit-making club
and we are not going to providing um
live clubbing events
we are an addition and a service and a
reward for our loyal clients
and i am in the salon today because
there is a rumor circulating that i am
converting the basement
of my premises into a club so
if there is any questions that anybody
would like to ask later
i can actually take you around
thank you there's a license in office i
have any questions for the applicant
no chairman it seems quite obvious to us
from the application that this isn't for
a
night club or any form of club it is
purely
to enhance people's experience at the
premises thank you
does the environmental protection
officer have any questions for the
applicant
he's not here because he didn't have any
major concerns
okay thank you um do the member the
republic have any questions for the
applicant
no
yes do you have any questions for the
applicant
um i just wanna at one stage i'd like to
just put my objections forward
yes um is that a question or do you want
to
to um no no
no no
does the applicant have any oh no that's
the police they're not here
do the environmental protection officers
have any questions for the applicant
no they had no concerns
do the members of the committee oh no
that's police again
would the environmental protection
officers please present their
no case think we need to ask the
committee if they have any questions for
the applicant
all right yes please chair
i don't uh joe i just wanted to uh clear
clear up one or two things
so will the alcohol be sold to people
or is it a sort of a freebie as part of
a treatment
and when i read the application you
obviously have you you'll have your
clients your your
individual clients coming in but then
you seem to be running some workshops
so i get some beauty workshops
uh bringing people in and and and
looking at products
i'm gonna interject
um first of all the service of alcohol
um is only for club members
so okay in order to be a club member you
have to be a client within my salon
the reason i've applied for a club
premises certificate is because i do not
want members of public
in my salon and they are entitled to
one free measured drink and
during their stay um if they're having a
treatment
if they would like an extra drink that
those drinks are charged for
okay and that's partly because i want to
make sure that
i'll be regulating what is coming out
obviously
um so and also if you're just a normal
client that's coming into the town
you're not entitled to any outcomes you
have to be a club you have to
be a club member you have to join
now then aside from that i have ideas
that i would like to run
um promotional events we do run
promotional events anyway
um in this industry um but obviously i'd
like to be able to
serve light refreshments and at these
events these events usually amount to
about
10 people and you're they are
specifically invited so you would only
be invited if you're part of the vip
and you would come and attend a workshop
so what a workshop means is it it might
be that we have a product that's been
released
and the therapist demonstrates that from
a product with a group pretending to
observe it and they might experience
something within that time
there might be some refreshments so
there's separate things
i'd also like to point out that and
because of this community feel that i'm
trying to develop
that i would like to have something that
maybe a little cinema evening where i
would invite my clients to come along
and and
watch maybe a film with us and enjoy
something a little bit different outside
and so that might be either within our
operating hours or slightly outside of
our normal
hair and skin operating out that would
be within our license
right now does that help clear up
but does thank you yes please
counselor yes uh joe i'm a little bit
confused so
when you're saying that you're offering
uh free drinks
um are they your clients your members
who are coming into the
club do they need to have the treatment
to receive these free drinks or
do can any of you remember come and
have drinks with you so
as the club rules stipulate if you are
a club member you have to be a club
member to be served alcohol that's the
first point
if you are attending an appointment so
if you have a hair appointment or beauty
appointment
you are a club member you can have one
free glass bank
if you're staying a little longer than
that because yeah i do have a social
area within
my salon which is not operational at the
moment because of kobe but
it will be long term if they want to
stay and assist and have a chat
and they can and they can have another
glass of outcome
because what i'm trying to do is i'm
trying to create an experience where
they don't feel they're going to rush
off
but they feel like they're part of this
experience that's
one thing and we can run the facility
where
if they are a club member they can call
in advance
if they're in town and make a basket
come sit in our garden
or sit within our social area with one
upstairs that i'm sitting at on one
downstairs
and they can sit and have a glass of
wine and at this point because they're
coming in outside of their treatment
times they're looking to purchase that
outcome
and that alcohol is also restricted um
to what each member is entitled to
and that's because of timings and
situations
and you cannot bring in anybody else
unless they are
a guest you can only bring in one guest
that have to be signed
in and i also have a limit to how many
people
so do you have the limit number yes
so my total in the building is 50.
that's my own personal limit i don't
have to make a limit
thank you
i would also point out that in a very
large building
but was that 50 what 500 as opposed to
one five
thank you
do the councillors have any any other
questions before we move on
no thank you this is the point of the
meeting
which the members of the public get to
make their representations mr haddon
please can you make your representation
yes can you hear me yes thank you
excellent okay i'm representing the
immediate neighbor
property um i am the leaseholder of
number 11 high street
which runs the entire length above 7
to 10 high street the shops below
and i'm also the co-owner of the
residential residential properties
adjacent to this application
and that i fear is where the issue is
i've spent a lot of money on
building a home down there we've got our
private garden
we've been living there for many many
years and the only peace and quiet we
actually get
being in the old town is in the rare
garden
because the front is occupied by the
parade and there's noises
everywhere else and we've enjoyed this
for a long time
living adjacent to the officers and
adjacent to a successful hairdresser
which was in the location of number
seven for the past 20 years
which is now a combined hair and beauty
salon
i took on the property number 11 high
street because it's a large office
and developed a
software development organization from
there where i
employ people and the reason for doing
that
is because it was defined as an office
above and
shop stroke retail below so i knew i'd
be able to enjoy the relative
peace and quiet that an i.t company
needs
[Music]
the other issue is that um the outside
area
of the building the total building
is for storage and also acts as a fire
escape route for the above offices
number 11
which if we house in six to ten people
is an important requirement
this is in my office lease the only exit
from the rear of their premises
including number sevens
is up a very steep vertical wooden
staircase
that will not take more than one person
at a time
and you have to be very agile to use it
having groups of people however small
and in this case
up to 50 drinking and gathering in the
red
area or having to use the rear area
in case of any issue will impede the
leases of the complex 7011
and endanger the staff and everyone
after sunset the exit area is badly lit
this is another health and safety issue
that needs to be resolved
by both leaseholders and the landlords
the applicant mentions phone evenings
and events for mums and children and
this makes it even more of a concern
to allow this to be blocked off and used
as a drinking area
possesses health and safety risks and
needs an alteration to the leases
for the office number seven is also
surrounded by buildings that are
residential as i've mentioned in my
opening statement
drinking outside and allowing late night
fools
and stuff is to act as a club however
well controlled is detrimental
to our sort of peace and and sort of
um requirements of a residential place
we don't need to add direct and close-up
noise and disturbances to the garden
areas of both number five and number
twenty
because it also depending on the hours
will be a disturbance to the office
workers
and is another public nuisance no one
can control drinking quantities
moreover outside smoking and noise
and we all know that a small group can
make a lot of noise a large group can
make an exceptional amount of noise
market street car park
is already a major problem area for
drinkers using them as al fresco toilets
and a dumped ground and this shares a
fence with number seven to eleven
high street the problem is
that when drinking is allowed the
business owners lock up and go home
needing us residents and the council to
clean up every day
and i say this in the like that the
applicant is saying you know it's an
extension
to their health and beauty salon
although i can't see why drinking
comes into it but then in the next
breath
there's a mention of soul weekends and
pride weekends as a reason
for a late license i just understand
what's that got to do with hair and
beauty
establishment um
you know to open a club in the same
premises of a shop is not the way to
supplement
income to the detriment of the
surrounding residents
sorry am i back again yes
um don't know how
when did i go on mute
two minutes a minute yeah but take
deception be told their family should
not be living in the old town
as there are hundreds of families living
in the old town and it's purely the
imbalance of drinking establishments
that is the problem not the residents
having purchased extensive properties
and trying to live normal and peaceful
lives
the real concern is opening hours
making use of the outside areas that
border on the private
residence and the proper gardens of
number 20 and number five
um and now we're hearing people you know
up to 50 people
it's it's a major worry and a
definitely a nuisance to our private
living
thank you thank you
does the applicant have any questions
um yeah can you hear me yes thank you
not so much questions but just
to stipulate again that on a normal
working day within this city salon we
can have up to 30 people here
and they just made any complaint about
noise and that
it's not a regular occurrence where
there would be up to 50 people
irregular activity which is enhancing
your business
and
thank you do members of the committee
have any questions
we don't have miss wilcox here do we
yeah no she hasn't joined us
[Music]
okay so i think we're to be summing up
stage yes i think we are
i would now like to ask each party to
sum up and make final representations
uh mr hadden would you like to sum up
yes thank you so much
in summary i'm very concerned about the
um
the afternoon operating hours i've been
able to serve
drink and entertain people
because it will certainly affect the
residents they're in hours
obviously there's a potential affecting
to the offices
above you've got a very careful look at
those hours
go very carefully look at the knock-on
effect of
having the pup in the back garden
drinking
because of the noise and the potential
smoking
and other disturbances and look at the
number of people gathering in an
area that is effectively a common parts
area to the entire premises
um and an an escape route
at the rear there's a huge there's an
extreme
close proximity to the outside area of
this
location we share common garden walls
with number 20 and number five and
of course quiet offices above at number
seven and i'd like
these issues to be taken into account on
behalf
of the workers at number 11 and the
residents at number
25 and in the surrounding area to be
quite honest
not just us we've just gone out of our
way to to try and find
a balance for all this drinking in the
immediate area
thank you thank you would the applicant
like to sum up now please
yeah so i think that it's important to
um reiterate again this is not a club
base for profit it's a non-profit making
club
and the residents will notice no
difference to the current trading
at all um there it is a non-smoking
venue
and we do not prioritize alcohol as our
standing point
and after hours we will only open our
normal
opening hours which are within the
operating hours of the license
but i have applied for a later license
up till 10 pm
if we use that license for additional
events
and overall we're very responsible aware
of our environment aware of our
neighbors
uh and will not have any intentions
whatsoever
in causing any uh nuisance um
and at the moment all of this objection
is only based on presumption it's not
actually based on any factual evidence
and so i think that it would only be
right for me to prove
that i am able to maintain
and maintain our good relationships
around the area
thank you thank you very much the
members of the subcommittee will now
leave this meeting
along with the council's legal
representative to deliberate this matter
in private we shall resume here to
deliver a verdict in 30 minutes time
whilst we leave the meeting i will ask
the democratic service officer to
explain the retiring process
thank you thank you as the chairman
said uh we will be meeting back here at
half past 12 and so you can either stay
in this meeting
and put your microphone and video um on
mute and
turn your video off or you can choose to
leave the meeting entirely and come back
using the same link as you used to log
into this meeting initially
so we'll see you back here at half past
12 for the decision
thank you yeah maybe we should carry on
then
in that case okay thank you
um i would now like to invite ms
phillips the principal litigation
solicitor to read a summary
of the subcommittee's determination
thank you very much
the decision today is as follows in the
application of joe
tully for a new premises certificate for
the gold room vip private club
at seven high street margate kent ct91dl
the fanec district council has the
relevance licensing authority
in accordance with section 12 of the
licensing act and upon
consideration of the representations
made to the committee today
which included um the licensing
authority
launched in the form of in the person of
alison brock the applicant mrs tully
and representations made by the member
of the public
robin hadden it is the decision of the
subcommittee
to grant the application but subject to
one
condition in relation to the applicants
um which has been made and we've
considered the effect
of it on the four licensing objectives
and we have considered that it
doesn't negatively impact the objective
of preventing crime and disorder
we've considered that it will not um
detract from the safety to the public
but in relation to the prevention of a
nuisance
we've decided to apply a condition which
includes that
no live and recorded music or
entertainment
um take place at the back of the
premises
at any time and there was no issue in
relation to the objective
of protecting children from harm and
that's our decision today
thank you thank you
thank you that concludes the business
for this meeting of the licensing
subcommittee
sorry could i just clarify when you say
no recorded or live music at the back of
the premises are you meaning outside
yes yes yes thank you
thank you thank you okay thank you for
your attendance
thank you thank you
bye bye
bye everyone